so for my birthday last year my husband
got me an Amazon echo I was kind of
shocked actually because we both work in
privacy and security and this is a
device that would sit in the middle of
our home with a microphone on constantly
listening we're not alone though
according to a survey by NPR and Edison
research one in six American adults now
has a smart speaker which means that
they have a virtual assistant at home
like that's wild the future or the
future dystopia is getting here fast
beyond that companies are offering us
all kinds of Internet connected devices
they're smart lights smart locks smart
toilets smart toys smart sex toys being
smart means the device can connect to
the internet it can gather data and it
can talk to its owner but once you're
done your appliances can talk to you who
else are they going to be talking to I
wanted to find out so I went all in and
turned my one-bedroom apartment in San
Francisco into a smart home I even
connected our bed to the Internet as far
as I know it was just measuring our
sleeping habits I can now tell you that
the only thing worse than getting a
terrible night's sleep is to have your
smart bed tell you the next day that you
missed your goal and got a low sleep
score it's like thanks smart bed as if I
didn't already feel like [ __ ] today all
together I installed 18 Internet
connected devices in my home I also
installed a Surya hi I'm Surya and I'm
onna turd everything the smart home did
I built a special router they let me
look at all the network activity you can
think of my router sort of like a
security guard compulsively logging all
the network packets as they entered in
left smart room sorry and I are both
journalists he's not my husband we just
work together at Gizmodo thank you for
clarifying the devices catch me but we
were interested in
understanding what they were saying to
the manufacturers but we were also
interested in understanding what the
homes digital emissions looked like to
the Internet service provider we were
seeing what her ISP could see but more
importantly what they could sell we ran
the experiment for two months in that
two months there wasn't a single hour of
digital silence in the house not even
when we went away for a week yet so -
based on the data and you and you guys
woke up and I knew when you went to bed
I even you and catch me brushed her
teeth I'm not gonna out your brushing
habits but let's just say it was very
clear to me when you were working from
home I think you just added them to like
a lot of people here don't be
embarrassed it's just metadata I knew
when you turned on your TV and how long
you watched it for fun fact about the
hill household they don't watch a lot of
television but when they do it's usually
in binge mode favorite shows include
difficult people in party down ok you're
right
I love party down it's a great show and
you should definitely watch it but
difficult people was all my husband
Trevor and Trevor was actually a little
upset that you knew about his binges
because even though he'd been the one to
connect the TV to the router he forgot
that the TV was watching us it's
actually not the first time that our TV
has spied on us the company that made it
Vizio paid a 2.2 million dollar
settlement to the government just last
year because it had been collecting
second-by-second information about what
millions of people are watching on TV
including us and then it was selling
that information to data brokers and
advertisers ah classic surveillance
economy movies the devices catch me but
almost all ping the server's daily but
do you know which device was especially
chatty
the Amazon echo it contacted its servers
every three minutes regardless of
whether you were using it or not in
general it was disconcerting that all
these devices were having ongoing
conversations that were invisible to me
I mean I would have had no idea without
your router if you buy a smart device
you should probably know you're going to
own the device but in general the
company is going to own your data and
you know I mean maybe that's to be
expected you buy an Internet connected
device it's going to use the Internet
but it's strange to have these devices
moving into the intimate space
the home and allowing companies to track
our really basic behavior they're so
true even the most banal seeming data
can be mined by the surveillance economy
for example who cares how often you
brush your teeth well as it turns out
there's a dental insurance company
called bheem they've been monitoring the
customers smart toothbrushes since 2015
for discounts on their premiums of
course we know what some of you are
thinking this is the contract of the
modern world you give up a little
privacy and you get some convenience or
some price breaks in return but that
wasn't my experience in my smart home it
wasn't convenient it was infuriating
like I'll admit I love my smart vacuum
but many other things in the house drove
me insane like we ran out of electrical
outlets and I had to download over a
dozen apps to my phone to control
everything and then every device had its
own login you know my toothbrush had a
password and smart coffee especially was
just a world of hell which really cloud
powered coffee was in wasn't he working
for you are you maybe I'm naive but I
thought it was gonna be great like I
thought we just wake up in the morning
and we'd say Alexa make us coffee but
that's not how it went down we had to
use this really particular brand
specific phrase to make it work it was
Alexa asked the be more to run Quick
Start and this was just like this was
really hard to remember first thing in
the morning before you have had your
caffeine and apparently it was hard to
say because the echo dot that was right
next to our bed just couldn't understand
us so we would basically start every day
by screaming this phrase at the echo dot
and Trevor hated this he'd be like
please Kashmir just let me go to the
kitchen and push the button to make the
coffee run and I'd be like no you can't
we have to do it the smart way I'm happy
to report that our marriage survived the
experiment but just barely
if you decide to make your home smart
hopefully you'll find it less
infuriating than Kashmir did but
regardless the smart things you buy can
and probably are used to target and
profile you just
number of devices you have can be used
to predict how rich or poor you are
Facebook's made this stack and they've
also patented it all the anxiety that
you currently feel every time you go
online about being tracked is about to
move into your living room or into your
bedroom there's this sex toy called the
we-vibe you might wonder why a sex toy
connects to the Internet but it's for
two people who are in a long-distance
relationship so they can share their
their love from afar some hackers took a
close look at this toy and saw it was
sending a lot of information back to the
company that made it you know when it
was used how long it was used for what
the vibration settings were how hot the
toy got it was all going into a database
so I reached out to a I reached out to
the company and I said you know like why
are you collecting this really sensitive
data and they said well it's great for
market research but they were data
mining their customers orgasms and they
weren't telling them about it I mean
even if you're cavalier about privacy I
hope that you would admit that's a step
too far this is why I'm gonna keep my
sex toys dumb we're all very glad to
know that range from useful to annoying
but the thing they all had in common was
sharing data with the companies that
made them with email service providers
and social media we've long been told
that if it's free you're the product but
with the Internet of Things it seems
even if you pay you're still the product
so you really have to ask who is the
true beneficiary of your smart home you
are the company mining you look we're a
tech-savvy crowd here I think most of us
know that these things connect to the
internet and send it out and fine
maybe you're okay with living in that
commercial panopticon the others aren't
we need companies to rethink the design
of these devices with our privacy in
mind because we're not all willing to
participate in market research just
because a device we bought has a Wi-Fi
connection and I have to tell you even
when you're aware generally this is
happening it's really easy to forget
that normal household items are spying
on you it's easy to forget these things
are watching you because they don't look
like cameras they could
like well they could look like a dildo
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]